rapper bad baby reveals that she's
checked herself into a treatment
facility the seventeen-year-old whose
real name is Danielle Drago Lee shared
the news in a statement on social media
Wednesday morning writing quote danielle
has been working hard for the past few
years and made a positive decision to
take some much-needed time off to attend
to some personal issues the statement
continues quote for past weeks she has
been in a treatment center receiving and
continuing to receive professional
support the post ends with the teenage
rapper asking for privacy at this time
and promising to return better and
healthier than ever yep Tuesday bad baby
Instagram a black box in support of the
black lives matter movement prior to
that her last post was a selfie on May
14th the 17 year old rose to fame after
her September 2016 appearance on dr.
Phil went viral
hahaha by day since then she's been busy
releasing new music dad babies late a
single that's what I said dropped in
April and she's got a popular snapchat
show oh my new snapchat show bringing a
baby is basically it's just me being me
according to a press release the rapper
just finished shooting season two which
is scheduled to premiere this summer
after the first season received the
highest ratings of any reality show
dethroning Keeping Up with the
Kardashians
people like to say like I'm this
horrible disrespectful person and I
treat people like and I do this I do
that but it's like when you really look
into it you really see it's not like
that at all the singer has also made
headlines for her feuds with fellow
celebs including the time she threw a
drink at Iggy Azalea at the 2018 fashion
nova cardi B launch event in LA and her
feud with Skye Jackson earlier this year
resulted in the Disney Channel star
filing a restraining order against her
I'm tired of people thinking I'm someone
I'm not or hating me for a reason that
they shouldn't hate me for but bad baby
was singing a different tune about her
fellow female artist when et caught up
with her last March
Shh you know in this music industry it's
always females against females so I
tried to be everybody's frame you like
trying to be all cool worried about no
basic oh y'all look like stuff last year
Oh y'all must not look in the mirror Oh
y'all looking by the windows in the eye
[Music]